he wha what part of florida are you
moving to so fort lauderdale hell yeah i
love it yeah me too texas was on the
play but what do you mean me too i know
i know i like that this these are my
places i met the governor i met ron
desantis last
saturday at the ufc oh great
him and rogan met during in like the
middle of it there was like there's like
a break between the
the espn one the part and the when they
switch over to pay-per-view we had like
seven minutes yeah and
so rogan and me and his crew cam hayes
and all these people we jetted to this
green room that they had
cornered off with desantis and his
entire like 40 percent oh no people came
with them was it for yeah sure it was
like the florida secret service
anyway and um
coolest guy and literally pitched he's
like you guys need to move to florida
whenever you guys are done with your
texas when that when when stuff hits the
this the fans are crying out there yeah
we'll be waiting for you did he really
try to recruit you guys yeah yeah i love
that i love it
so did we by the way what's more
welcoming than coming come stay at my
house who's the who's your who's your
governor abbott yeah dude how boss is
that guy he took all the buses of all
the uh illegals
he bust them to d.c they started
arriving today and there's people with
umbrellas
they were taking selfies of like the cap
it was [ __ ] brilliant what was uh the
sanders sales pitch you said you had
seven minutes with him but what was that
that was just moving to florida yeah we
want you here um and and i go i said i
love the way that you handled uh the
pandemic man beautiful awesome
and he goes yeah who would have guessed
that you give the people the choice to
do what they want to do would work in
america brilliant ways said it i mean i
fell in love with this guy for the rest
of our lives he'll get any vote that he
ever runs for from me that's it common
sense and for some reason
that's what we seem to be like lacking
nowadays right it's a bunch of weird
[ __ ] happening meanwhile anybody that
has any common sense at all and that guy
is just common sense
uh he's
he's going to walk into the white house
i think he's going to he's going to
stroll in i don't know
well
he's got to win the republican primary
there's some guy there's some orange man
looming over the republican party right
now let me say let me say ah i was gonna
say i i would rather have and this
person i would rather have decent
because dude trump lover may hate him
it's a little too much bro and people
and imagine they're gonna have to dig up
there on desantis what what are you
gonna what collusion what all that what
are you gonna do he's he's a golden
child he's the one by the way but you
gotta you gotta be very careful
on how you sell him
because
if you sell them as the golden flawless
everybody has [ __ ] yeah of course some
is going to come out on the gear yeah
and market has to be ready there is
desantis has got uh stuff in the closet
so if you don't get it on i don't know
if it's gonna be as legendary as a
stormy and karen mcdougall type of stuff
because that guy took it to hold it from
level 100 you know but here's what just
happened i had a uh
ah okay so i had a conversation with kid
i can't tell you who but i had a
conversation
and you're giving me the who's in the if
if if
uh uh trump runs desantis is not running
i i mean it's less than a five percent
chance he's running if trump trump goes
if trump goes desantis is not running at
all is trump is the word in the street
that trump is going 99 he's wrong
because he's not going to be the vice
president so
so so that means he's going to wait till
2028 not 2024. so this is what that
means now so some people that are saying
oh my god this is if anybody's ever
thought about moving to florida yeah
that means desantis is going to be the
governor until 2028. so that's a very
big insurance policy
for anybody that is thinking about
moving to florida because by 2020 that
gives them six more years to find
somebody to replace him because that's
the key you got also find somebody to
replace him but if trump runs which
there's a 99 percent chance he's running
he's not gonna be running but there's a
there's a problem with him waiting that
long right now he's hot he's how many
who's
we've talked about exactly of course we
agree but i'm just telling you
he does not want to go face off because
he knows trump's going to talk [ __ ] and
he's going to talk
santa's not going to just sit there and
tell you all you guys do you think if
trump was trump won and trump was still
in this
woke i mean because the old movement's
been going but all the stuff that
they're they've been trying to pull and
all that stuff would it be happening or
it would not or i mean he would be
bodying these people on twitter and out
in public speeches i think people forget
exactly how funny yeah hilarious he was
the funniest one you mean and it's like
he again he's another guy that love him
or hate him i mean was calling out this
stuff before everybody i mean he's
literally not on twitter anymore yeah is
that crazy but they're crazy like
there's people that are like in on isis
and [ __ ] that smoke spoken tweet it's
funny yeah vladimir putin's on twitter
100 and donald trump isn't yeah who's
yeah 100 and so and there's a reason for
that you know someone that doesn't want
him talking about all of this
that is their agenda period so i mean
that's everything that's why this elon
musk thing is an actual thing buying
twitter no because of that it's the
blatant thing that he's going to do
it's obvious it's all about free speech
so how could he
keep a former president banned that's
how possible what's the what's the
chances that if musk
succeeds and this poison bill doesn't
work that trump gets back on oh i think
100 okay yeah i think that's the
statement he's going to show exactly how
he's going to show exactly how free free
speech is do you realize here's the
following thing
if
he buys
twitter
at 52 bucks
and he lets trump on twitter stock will
go to 200 100
by the way it's just a prediction
i'm just telling you brilliant it's
going to work he buys
52 bucks is underpriced with musk owning
it
i think twitter stock has the ability
from 52 to even 10x within a five-year
period
so that's that's just a possibility of
what could happen
look at how much they were quoting
twitter twitter was the news for those
four years here's what trump said today
it was them reporting about twitter
trump will be back on tweeting 40 times
a day oh my god
yeah
the greatest troll of all time will be
back on again is the goat if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]